c'est l'histoire d'une fille qui en fait
euh
elle a un complexe
depuis quelques temps elle a la chatte
qui sent l'oignon
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
le temps de faire un gars qui lui plaît
tout ça et puis alice est célibataire il
fait oui oui
mais pourquoi tu pourquoi tu parles
comme ça en fait j'ai un problème j'ai
un complexe je sens rien j'ai pas
d'odorat
ça peut le faire du coup elle le ramène
chez lui puis elle a très très envie de
lui alors elle prend sa tête elle la met
entre ses jambes et puis là il fait
qu'est-ce qu'il y a
tu m'avais pas dit tu avais la chatte à
l'oignon
normalement
j'ai les yeux qui pleurent
c'est une blonde balade dans la rue et
elle trouve un pingouin
et tu es tout seul mais qu'est-ce que tu
fais là
elle prend le pingouin il est moyen un
peu lourd elle croise un flic elle tu
vois monsieur l'agent que comment
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire de ce
pingouin
il y avait dit bah écoutez je sais pas
moi je suis la circulation bah emmener
le haut
deux jours après il la recroise et puis
avec le pingouin et tout ils s'entendent
bien puis il fait mais comment ça se
fait que vous avez vous êtes encore avec
les pingouins elle dit bah je sais pas
vous m'avez dit de l'emmener au zoo
maintenant ce soir on va au cinéma
[Applaudissements]
on va faire un jeu on va jouer à
cache-cache si jamais je te trouve
qu'est-ce qu'on gagne celui qui trouve
l'autre
bah il l'enfile ah ok alors je vais me
cacher puis si tu me trouves pas je suis
dans le placard
[Applaudissements]
derrière il fait non mais ça suffit
j'entends rien
en même temps ça vous regarde pas
beaucoup
très longtemps alors attends
elle en a marre donc effectivement et je
vais aller acheter des godes ça suffit
donc elle arrive dans le magasin
il y a plusieurs tailles c'est un peu
comme dans ta boutique et donc oh voilà
le jaune là le jaune il est bien il est
un peu plus large etc puis le bleu bah
le bleu il est un peu plus rond au bout
ah d'accord et bah du bas c'est très
bien je vais prendre le jaune le bleu et
le rouge les deux premiers c'est
possible mais pour l'extincteur faut
voir que le patron
c'est un kangourou qui rentre dans un
bar et donc barman il est un peu étonné
tout ça donc il arrive il dit voilà bah
je voudrais un coca ok là
20 euros et le barman le regarde
vraiment vraiment bizarrement dit mais
c'est le kangourou il fait quoi c'est ce
qu'il y a tu peux pas ma gueule non non
c'est pas ça c'est juste que ça fait
très longtemps qu'on a pas vu de
kangourou ici ah c'est normal avec un
coca 20 euros
[Applaudissements]